we're not gonna be little
children anymore we're gonna go into
this as a job we're gonna take it
seriously and we're gonna make it to the
top
tsm cement themselves as the greatest
team north america has ever seen
six championships and ten splits they
have never missed a final
they have never missed worlds and they
are once again
your north american champion and his
prime he was definitely top two
if not the best in a mid laner strictly
just because he was able to make these
kind of calls that would win gift
they go to playoffs and choke it's on
them it's on us it's on me
the nexus is going down and team solomid
are destroyed
tsm crowded the game
over i find it absolutely unbearable
for us to take anything below top two
[Applause]
back in 2009 a small indie game
developer out of santa monica california
launched their inaugural game it was
called league of legends
clash of fates and among the first 100
people to ever play the game
was a teenager by the name of andy
reginald
din and he didn't like it at that point
i thought the game was like
pretty bad to be honest and so i
actually i actually quit the game
because i came from dota
and there wasn't lock screen but
i i found like i played league with
blockchain i didn't know that i could
unlock the screens i quit for a while
and i came back
after that reggie was hooked and while
playing with his brother dan
discovered he had a natural talent for
the game
together the din brothers founded a
league of legends community forum called
solomid.net
while the duo ran their website they
were also competing on a team called
all or nothing but because reggie and
his brother were both trying to call the
shots
reggie decided to briefly play for
counter logic gaming
feeling he could do better on his own
reggie decided it was time
to start a team tsm was formed because
i was on clg and then i wanted a team
for my site so i was like yo
rain man joined my team and he was like
oh i need a computer i was like yeah
i'll get you and peter
so i like grabbed him to be my hoe and
then i guess about chaos because he's
some asian guy that wanted to be good at
league of legends
after going through a few early roster
iterations the tsm lineup settled
on reginald the odd one chaox the rain
man
and x special the newly formed tsm would
attend the first league of legends world
championship
in yongshaping sweden where they would
test their medal against the best
north america southeast asia and europe
had to offer
right here they're going to get it first
but tsm going to be right behind them
and here comes the fight it's going to
be
singed in front a great car that's all
they're going to help the initiate
there's a stun but they're blowing
up rain man that's the wrong person to
go for the damage output is huge candy
panda drops out first xylo in the middle
a good opener from nunu and the channel
looks like candy panda yet indeed didn't
go down now tarek is the next one
he's gonna drop for free and looks like
wow four kills for nothing wonderful
fight from tsm on the battle
and we're gonna have to see the cue or
the ice blast coming out of the odd one
a lot of damage coming out huge damage
onto tyrus will he go down standing in
the ultimate double lift uh
able to take a little bit more damage
tristana also falls tsm
just absolutely thwarting what epic
thought they could do into that fight
the clear points going down as they
flash over the wall dan dan
also falling to the ground sulsi the
next target they have saucy in a 2v1
situation
here comes the odd one going out for the
quick steal and it looks like they're
going to be able to take him down as he
throws down the nose zone to do what he
can before he goes down
tsm on the ace ultimately tsm would
place third at the event
losing to against all authority good
game against all authority are going to
go
straight in that nexus is going to fall
and we will see an all-european grand
final here for season one
but that disappointment was short-lived
when riot announced season 2 which would
field a huge international tournament
circuit
with 5 million dollars in prize pools
and a chance to play at the season 2
world championship reggie was thrilled
and he wanted tsm to take the season 2
circuit
seriously so he moved the team into a
gaming house
in long island new york it was not a
calculated business decision at all
i just really decided to add a passion i
wanted to compete
and that passion was more important to
me than anything money
whatever it was there tsm would commit
to a tougher scrim schedule
and focus on league of legends full-time
but the team's top laner
christian the rain man common had
different ideas
for me as an individual player i feel
like
just screaming all day wasn't making me
better as a player so
that's why i was feeling the way i was
feeling i think my skill had
gone a general decline he didn't want to
do our practice schedule and he said it
was a waste of time he did not feel like
we would be able to win season two if we
stuck with that practice schedule
reggie and rainman had been friends but
if he wasn't willing to put in the work
reggie and tsm would move on without him
eventually
marcus dyrus hill who was living in the
house at the time
replaced rain man on the team for reggie
pushing this new work ethic
and moving forward with dyrus was just
the first of many points
where he'd have to put his position as
team owner ahead
of his personal relationships and with
dyrus they found success
almost immediately champions we have the
last fight from clg trying to come in
here
dyrus just too strong though with that
pull over them the ash is slow
chasing him down saint vicious is going
to go down hotshot going to be chased
as well he will back off but this is
going to be the game we're going to have
the nexus here right after the
inhibitors here give some noise
you know they're sitting off to the side
they're waiting for it get that tsm
check going because they are the ipl for
champions
as tsm scrimmed out of their long island
gaming house the rest of the nascent
western esports scene was developing
around them and reggie was beginning to
cement himself as one of na's
greatest mids trump is not going to like
this he's going to try to jump out
directly
around retro goes for a dark finding he
will land it perfect
there the
[Applause]
he was definitely top two if not the
best in a mid laner strictly just
because
he was able to make these kind of calls
that would win gigs
they're going to go in anyway jumping in
so much damage they will break it but
they pulled in
that's not what you want right there
after zero goes up but we're going to
keep them alive
do they have the damage chaos taking a
bit of pain but cutie fights not gonna
make him die
let's see if they have what it takes
anybody's still getting chased down
chaos very very threatening here
and no tsm will walk away with two easy
kills
we were together and we played as a team
and i and i attribute that to myself is
that i was able to pull everyone on the
same page
five people doing one thing wrong is
better than five guys
doing five different things right driven
by their fearless shot calling leader
tsm established themselves as north
america's premier
league of legends team but instead that
the unstoppable force comes in once
again from director he's going to dive
into zingy doing his best of chance he
can
aka fat mama and that's a double kill
straight away going for that dredge line
he does land it dyrus locked out now
taunted hazard
trying to do the damage dyrus with his
ultimate down turns on to pick that lp
rune prison will still allow dyrus to
attack and he is going to be able to
take him out
with the help of the odd one they are
now pushing back hazard
and hotshot gg it looks like to get
smoked and slowed the wall of pain
could this be the ace they're looking
for it's going to be hot shot down
hazard follows shortly after and galio
finally coming up towards the eighth but
all five members of clg
did fall turrets but the turret is about
to go down as well here comes chaos
the room on the 80 carry and he may be
caught out of position
it is down here comes the lulu wild
throne they focus one down
torky falls and they will they be able
to get
and they're going to turn this around
for a counter if special might find
himself another kill here
he takes out drums and scarra will go
down
the odd one walks out cleanly tsm were
riding high heading into the season two
world championships
and as na's top seed they guaranteed
themselves a spot in the quarterfinals
their opponents korea's azubu frost
frost dominated group a and entered the
quarterfinal showdown with supreme
confidence and while tsm fought
valiantly over the course of two games
in the end frost proved to be too much
for them to handle it
there's only two there and cloud templar
is quite hurt
he is the one to take that turret mad
life may go down here and he does
but they drop down tyrus the ace is
there freak the nexus turrets are going
down
cloud templar is so tanky they're trying
to thwart out team solomid
trying to stop that path to the
championship and atubu frost
will knock out team solomid but their
defeat
was not without controversy 30 seconds
into the game when were four
four west up or at the tower there was a
pause a very seven pause by zebra frost
and ironically we were having problems
with our chats
our chats weren't working our computers
were slow we did not care
we just wanted to play and as soon as we
saw that pause we're like holy [ __ ] our
plan might not work
we looked straight to zoo frost and
chaos notices
their players looking at our map looking
at the mini map
and they start like talking and then um
there's also proof in the replay that
there's been pings at dark areas where
we're standing where they have no vision
of
so i mean that's kind of
shady in my opinion despite a
frustrating end to season two
tsm's disappointment was short-lived as
riot announced that they would be moving
to a league system in north america
and europe and as one of the three n a
teams to have attended the world
championship
tsm were guaranteed a spot in it they
entered the spring split as one of the
strongest teams in n a
and immediately looked the part so this
could be one of the last fights they're
going in
the bullet time clearly hitting every
member of dignitas
and it completely softens them up for a
quick one two three
and it looks like four and five are
forced to the the fountain
dignitas watches their nexus go down as
team solomid
finds another win in the lcs be a big
global map lead
at least in vision oh man they're gonna
be stopped just short of taking the
turret down one after the other of crowd
control
gente may find himself going down he
gets a great light binding but there's
just too much burn
the last hit from the odd one picks
himself up a kill and dyrus finds an
equalizer ultimate kill there's a power
second there we go another engage from
odd one odd one goes in quickly but he
gets
locked up there for a second finally
gets his bearings back and he kind of
puts down the cataclysm but he gets
knocked out of it himself they're able
to take down a good
two there great job coming in from
reginald with the double kill
mia trying to throw himself over he
finds the odd one in a party
and it looks like they're gonna disperse
from this one three to one
complexity looks hurt here as nick wu
gets caught it could be a four for one a
few
last attacks reginald picking up three
in the overall fight but while they look
strong throughout the first five
weeks an increasingly large disconnect
began to form between a.d carry
shan chaoks huang and reggie resulting
in jason
wild turtle tran being brought in as the
new adc
and his debut on the team was explosive
darius thank you very low louder is
still yet to use against the sad mommy
there it is he goes out crescendo hits
the entire complexity team though
can they turn it around wild turtle out
the back just hitting hitting one after
the other there's a double kill for him
louder modest goes in that's going to
feed him a triple kill
m.i.a that's going to be a quadra kill
can he get the pentagon
front you 101 it's gonna be the pentagon
for a
beautiful play wild tunnel stepping up
chaos you have something to answer right
now because your replacement is doing a
fantastic job
and that is the game for team solomid
though reggie and chaox were close
friends
reggie wanted a very specific culture in
tsm
one that prioritized hard work above
everything else
you don't show up to practice late
constantly and expect
to not get punished that's how a job
works when you're late consistently you
get fired
friendly doesn't help well too bad fire
me now we have to set a precedent
because
if someone gets away with something
something that bad it's it's not good
for anything it's just toxic once again
reggie had to choose business
over friendship resulting in the team
moving forward with turtle
instead of chaox while turtle may not
have been miles ahead of other adcs in
na at the time
his attitude better matched reggie's
vision for tsm he wasn't that much
better than chaox but because he took
the game a lot more seriously at that
point
he had a much higher ceiling and we were
super excited about that but the reason
why
tsm became a lot better was because by
getting rid of chaos because he wasn't
serious
it made everyone on our team be more
serious with a boost from turtle
tsm went on to win the first n-a-l-c-s
split chance there masmi is trying to
run them out of the base he says follow
me
not the nexus but it looks too good for
tsm right now this is gonna be it for
tsm i think we have our champion there
it is tsm in game five looks to be your
north american lcs spring champions they
take down the nexus
and the title
but in the summer a new obstacle emerged
in the form of cloud9
a plucky team of newcomers who had
qualified through the first split of
north american challenger
as quantic gaming tsm was still a strong
team that summer but cloud9 were a force
and when it came time for the playoffs
reggie and the rest of tsm were simply
no match has used a crochet now has used
the exhaust
everything is defensive right now for
tsm to get out and
hit the nexus with their eyes on the
nexus their eyes on the summer split
completely undefeated in the series 25
and three
on the split cloud nine does not drop a
single game in the playoffs one
disappointment would lead to another
and tsm bombed out of groups in the
season three world championship
one of reggie's lane opponents at worlds
was a young mid lane prodigy
who was playing outside of korea for the
first time even then
it was obvious that against a player
like faker
reggie was out of his depth that farm
going on reginald putting some pressure
down but faker actually turned him down
a lot of damage
reginald goes aggressive pushes
ultimates out faker
his mechanical ceiling was so much
higher than mine
that i felt like i was put in a position
where i had to play to not lose
and go even i could tell you uh it was
one of like the most uncomfortable
playing experiences
that i've had in my career reginald
found himself in a difficult position
he was a veteran of the professional
scene a pioneer that had helped pave the
way
for the western esports boom but he was
also a mid-laner on a team
that would only face stiffer competition
heading into
2014 a mid laner who unlike his rivals
owned his team because of the
responsibilities that came with being a
team owner
reggie couldn't play as much as his
players he couldn't throw himself into
solo queue after scrims
he couldn't fully dedicate himself to
the game
and he needed someone who could
i'm bjergsen how did you guys see the
new mid laner who the
[ __ ] are you soren bjergsen bjerg had
been making a name for himself
in the european lcs as a bright star on
a struggling
copenhagen wolves roster he might be
interested in having to go with this one
is he going to get the fling it's
virtually thrown to the side freddie
gets a lulu ultimate down on him as
desire ulti knocks him all in the edge
leia
being absolutely destroyed his fence
current comes in as well there was the
lulu ultimate wasn't used earlier on
bjergsen is going to kill virtual though
freddie going low knee got bro going low
no no he's finished off corellias and
freddie are the only two men left alive
here
god bro he's still somehow alive in this
one as he flings freddie away again
kill can he get the pentakill here
bjergsen chasing down oh he's missing
just about there
coming in for bjergsen despite
bjergsen's potential the decision to go
with him was a difficult one
especially because another far more
experienced mid laner
was in the mix enrique expec cedino
martinez
reggie was his team's primary shot
caller he needed someone who could fill
those shoes
so the choice to go with a young
relatively unproven mechanical genius
over a proven legend in expec
was a risky one initially bjergsen
struggled as the team's in-game leader
but it was something reggie would help
him learn
over time kind of saying well it's their
fault because four of them are there
then basically what you're doing is
you're not even shot calling you're just
basically asking people questions
like should we fight or not like i never
wanted to do this
that's an overall shot call that's a
college point they get all the
information they need and they make a
final decision
my problem there is no one made a call
people should be actively feeding the
information
and then you should make a final call
after falling again to cloud9 in the
spring 2014
finals reggie made further roster
changes bringing in amazing
and lust boy and with their new jungle
earned support tsm finally wrenched the
title back
from their rivals in the summer this is
the disengage that team solomid has the
talent there's dyerson already used
meteos throwing down the ultimate but he
only gets one a lot is being
used for only the few members of team
solomid here with all the artillery
coming in from bjergsen on the back side
because it's finalizing
no it's gonna be wild there's gonna be a
penalty
for the penta but balls won't give it to
him the quadra kill instantly coming up
the team that had first stormed across
the n a scene was
almost unrecognizable with dyrus being
the last old guard member
of the roster but despite the new
players tsm still played largely
like tsm they focused around a strong
decisive mid laner and they use support
from the jungle to take the pressure
off their other lanes why is this big
engaged tires just out of flange on that
hope that wears off
not much damage from the shock wave but
the control tsm needs to reassess the
fight
boss gets hit up the glacial fish are on
the back side they bottlenecked into
this fight and are going for bro
hai goes in tries to get his ultimate
down left last breath has already been
used
coming up with focus
[Applause]
2014 tsm would have to once again
fight for their spot in the top eight
but after making it through the group
stage they ran into one of the
tournament favorites
in samsung white undefeated records kda
leaders and four out of the five
positions on this team
tsm were clearly outmatched and though
they managed to get a win off the back
of some
questionable drafting by white they
found themselves
overwhelmed let's see we're not done yet
man he wants to keep fighting here
well they have some pretty long death
timers i think they're just waiting for
the backup
securing the second inhibitor look at
that next short this should be series
amazing gets the next yasuo oh and he
gets the final cue from pawn
that's four members down bjergsen doing
what he can to stay alive but it's not
gonna be enough
white will take down team solomid in the
quarterfinals
although 2014 ended in international
disappointment for tsm
reggie was undergoing evolution as a
team owner
2015 saw the tsm brand expand into a
number of games outside of league of
legends
in january tsm acquired the danish cs go
team
that would go on to become astralis
featuring dupree
zipic's device cajun b and kerrigan the
roster
was a dominant force throughout much of
the 2015 season
cementing themselves as one of the best
teams in the world
it was reggie's first big statement that
tsm was interested in being more
than just a league of legends team but
reggie wasn't satisfied with
only dipping his toes into cs go tsm
would go on to pick up players and
rosters in super smash bros
call of duty smite vainglory hearthstone
and more recently pubg and fortnite but
as tsm the organization was expanding
its league of legends team had begun to
falter
the team had suffered back-to-back
defeats in the lcs at the hands of clg
in summer 2015 and spring 2016
after a disappointing early exit from
worlds 2015's group stage
followed by dyrus's tearful departure at
the end of that event
it was clear that something needed to
change
the next year would be a transitional
one for tsm
as reginald attempted to reinvent the
championship winning formula and by the
summer of 2016
he'd done just that bjergsen doublelift
hauntzer svenskaran and biofrost formed
one of the most domestically dominant
teams
na has ever seen they adopted an
aggressive practice schedule designed to
mirror
korean teams squeezing potential out of
their new lineup
and in n a it worked so fun to the
raptor but rain over oh the slows
there's a lot of them csm i think
they've found a catch right there
oh thank you though but
[Applause]
the cast also silences them proto ship
design
yep it's on it he can get back into the
fight get the monster shield on for the
team
but everybody was hit by the crescendo
in the back line now they're trying to
catch up
from hauntzer's ultimate and they are
able to capitalize on the kills
when is doublelift knock off early kills
against immortals
roll it back once again and tsm comes up
huge in the bot lane
30 seconds sneaky can't get back to the
base just stop sneaking
moving in as well contract can they win
this 2v2 no sticky
he's too late that's it project's going
to get turned down as well
it's going to keep chasing it down and
tsm just keeps going 15 seconds left
and tsm are going to end it there's a
nice way here we go
[Applause]
it's going to be dardoch on the turret
garb going down fence guarant very low
stixxay goes down as well the one for
one there
and here comes doublelift out of the
base he finds a true arrow
eagle eye doublelift dropping down huhi
and tsm's
going coast to coast for the win tsm
cement themselves
as the greatest team north america has
ever seen
six championships in 10 splits they have
never missed a final
they have never missed worlds and they
are once again
your north american champion
but tsm's reign wouldn't extend beyond
their own region
and the team fell short on the
international stage again
gets himself the fourth the nexus is
going down
a team solo mate their hopes their
dreams
they're done and again the inhibitor
they don't even care about
they're looking for the kills and the
flash walls chase down
turtle for the ace and the next spot
the team solomon are destroyed
and again these misfits push themselves
straight into the quarterfinals and
there it is
agony in defeat here for tsm again
out in group stages in world 2017
and throughout this testing period
reggie had to learn another
tough lesson how to take a step back
from the team he'd poured his heart
and soul into throughout tsm's history
reggie had built a reputation for
inserting himself
into the team when things got tough most
notably in 2015
when he took over as head coach
enforcing his philosophies
about how a team should be run although
like you know community and everyone
believes that hey
reginald just steps in because he wants
to like get all the spotlight and run
his team
that's actually not the case i i'm
stepping in because
i find it absolutely unbearable for us
to
take anything below top two in most of
these instances
reggie got the results he wanted but
over time it became clear that he needed
to have
faith in the team and staff he'd built
in the empire
he'd helped create when reggie stepped
in it could hurt his coach's authority
and coaching infrastructure was becoming
a bigger part of the lcs
and it's a lesson he appeared to learn
in the 2018 spring split tsm struggled
to adapt to a new roster
and eventually was eliminated in the
playoff quarter finals
after a tough regular season they
rallied and won the game sven taking a
little bit of damage now mike young on
the front line going to be black
shielded up
dead dead taken down the redemption not
in time but it's now going to be
feminine on the front line fifty gonna
be taken very low
it's one for one so far support's gonna
be traded off
tsm routed the game
over and that is the end of this series
and the
end of tsm's perfect record of attending
the playoff finals
reggie though supportive of his players
and staff let the split
play itself out
[Music]
reggie's maturation from a teenage
league of legends enthusiast to the
owner of one of the biggest esports
brands in the world
had given him a platform and during an
interview in 2016
he used that platform to highlight the
risks of running a league of legends
franchise
and how the majority of the teams were
not making money from their lcs
ventures it's just an unstable
environment overall and
i would say it's really volatile for the
organizations and the players
like if you want to be you know a news
anchor or whatever it is you
put time into it you slowly improve
through the years and by the by the time
you're in it for 20 years you become an
absolute star and you're not nervous in
front of camera anymore
i kind of want that to be like my career
in esports where
i have i'm investing into something
stable and i think it's a combination of
the lack of revenue
and also how unstable the patches are
that really makes things
volatile in terms of investment
perspective right after reggie's
interview
riot co-founder mark tryndamere merrill
took to reddit with a now
infamous response that entirely missed
the point
that reggie had been attempting to make
the resulting backlash towards merrill
and riot from the community
led to a letter signed by most lcs team
owners asking
for a new system and by june 2017
riot announced a new franchise system in
north america
with multi-million dollar buy-ins
infrastructure and revenue sharing
the new nalcs has opened a debate about
what a modern esports league
should look like it's a big step for the
scene and a big step for esports
although the conversation about
franchising was no doubt happening
behind the scenes for some time
the public push on its behalf came in
part
because of reggie there is kind of a
difference in public
perception versus kind of like the real
reggie
i've seen him go out of his way to
take care of players and also set the
industry standard for player treatment
from the kid who just wanted to create a
community around league of legends to
one of the most
influential owners in a new franchised
era
reggie has come a long way there's no
question that
reginald was in the right place at the
right time that he got to know the right
people
but there's also no question that he
worked harder that he hustled
more and that he helped build the
western esports scene
around him that's the thing about reggie
and about tsm
you can love them or not you can cheer
for them or not
but in esports results are ultimately
what matter
and you can't argue with their results
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button